in this video you're going to learn
about what exactly is the perpendicular
bis sector theorem and what's the
converse of the perpendicular bis sector
theorem and how do we use those two
theorems to solve some problems so let's
dive into this video so when we talk
about a perpendicular bis sector what
does that mean well perpendicular means
it's at a right angle BCT means it cuts
it into two equal parts so cuts a
segment in half goes right through the
midpoint but what the perpendicular bis
sector theorem tells us is if I pick a
point on this perpendicular bis sector
of this segment right any anywhere along
this perpendicular bis sector say like
right here what do I know about this
length and this length so the distance
from the point on the perpendicular bis
sector to both end points of the segment
what do you know about those two lengths
well they're going to be congruent and
you learned in a previous lessons when
you proved triangles congruent remember
if this is a right angle this has to be
a right angle this side is shared
between these two triangles by the
reflexive property and remember you
learned this side angle side side angle
side that's enough to prove that the two
triangles are congruent to each other
which means by the
cpctc the corresponding parts of
congruent triangles will be congruent
basically if you fold this these two are
going to match up with one another and
they're going to be the same length
because the two triangles are congruent
so that's what the perpendicular bis
sector theorem is it just says again
let's just go through it again so if you
have a segment and you have a
perpendicular bis sector so it's
perpendicular right angles and it
bisects or cuts that in half and you
pick a point anywhere along that
perpendicular bis sector say right here
what do you know about this length and
this length they have to be congruent by
the perpendicular bis sector theorem
Okay now what's the converse well we
know from earlier in Geometry the
converse is like saying that conditional
statement in Reverse essentially you're
switching the hypothesis and the
conclusion and so what it's saying is
that say you have a segment and you have
a point that's not on that segment and
you measure the distances uh to the two
end points and you find that they're
congruent what do you know about that
point it has to lie on the perpendicular
bis sector right so notice what we can
do here if I drop a perpendicular right
perpendicular means it's at a right
angle okay and I know that this is the
same length in this triangle as it in
this triangle because it's shared right
that's the reflexive property and I know
that these two triangles are congruent
by the hypotenuse leg remember when we
Prov triangles congruent by HL the
hypotenuse leg so if with two triangles
are congruent then by cpctc or the
corresponding parts of congruent
triangles all the parts that match up
will be congruent meaning these two
segments are
congruent which means that what type of
a line is this it's a perpendicular bis
sector because it bisects it cuts it in
half and it's at a right angle so let's
look at that again in slow motion kind
of like when you're watching sports they
do the replay this is the replay right
we have our segment okay and we have a
point that's not on that segment and we
draw two segments to the end points of
that original segment and we find out
that they're the same length what does
it tell us about this point it must lie
on the perpendicular bis sector okay now
let's apply those theorems the
perpendicular bis sector theorem and the
converse to solve this problem number
one so how can we find out the length of
DC how can we find out what x is well
let's look at the clues right we know
that this is perpendicular because of
the right angle and we know it's
bisecting because these two segments are
congruent that means that D is on the
perpendicular bis sector of segment AC
so if we pick a point on that
perpendicular bis sector what do we know
about the distance to the end points of
the segment they're the same and again
if you ever forget this use what you
learned or what we talked about uh
proving triangles congruent and you can
see that oh this is shared between the
two triangles I have side angle side
side angle side by cpctc the
corresponding parts are congruent right
okay for number two now let's look what
we have we want to solve for
x we can see that we have this point M
which is not on segment Ln and the
distance to the end points is the same
see how these are both 15 what does that
tell us about Point M it lies on the
perpendicular bis sector we already can
see that it's perpendicular right but
it's going to lie on that perpendicular
bis sector uh because the distance to
the end points is the same now again if
you forget you you can prove it to
yourself fairly quickly you say well
this segment is shared between the two
triangles so it's congruent in both
triangles by the reflexive property the
hypotenuses are congruent this leg is
congruent and they're both right
triangles so by the hypotenuse leg the
two triangles are congruent by cpctc the
corresponding parts are going to be
congruent so these are equal to each
other so if we solve this equation 2x -
3 = x + 6 let's subtract X from both
sides let's add three to both sides
we're getting X is equal to
nine and you got it so great job now if
you like the way that I explain things
and you want to learn more about
geometry I'm going to put a playlist
right there that goes through 11 videos
working you through the important
Concepts and problems that you encounter
in a typical geometry course or class so
follow me to that playlist and I'll see
you over in those videos